kaylee we're going to take care of you
and get you on Bachelor life if you'll
accept after failing to get through busy
phone lines last week Bachelor Ben
Higgins invited kaley cuoco to be on
bachelor live on Monday Night the
actress accepted his invitation joining
us via Skype kaley cuoco well we have
you here and I have been so go ask
whatever you want is all of you I've
never been speechless I don't know what
to say yeah and you are the sweetest
those girls are insane the big bang
theory star joined by her younger sister
Brianna and a few girlfriends including
former bachelorette ali fedotowsky did
manage to ask one very important
question I need a spin one question can
I ask are you are you in LA uh you know
what I've chosen I think we're losing
our connection Bailey some sort of solar
flares we got to say goodbye Chris
Harrison was joined in studio by guest
Chris soules and Kris Jenner the momager
answered a fan question about which of
her kids if single would most likely go
on the dating show to find love it would
be who could I talk into it i would i
would say like one of the younger ones
but Kenda wouldn't go for it I don't
know I could talk them into it though